back in Bell Park courts are often a
gathering place in urban communities but
many are in bad shape that inspired one
hoop loving guy to start a nonprofit
that changes black tops from drab to fab
Jamie yuccas shows us how the
transformations are also inspiring some
kids to aim even higher at the rainbow
Recreation Center in Oakland the
basketball court has become a giant
canvas when I see a park in disrepair it
just makes me want to bring that space
back to life it's a little bit wet here
you can see like when the color is kind
of different
dan Peterson is the visionary behind
this vibrant transformation I love
outdoor basketball in public parks his
love of basketball began as a teen Danny
from way down town money fast forward to
2015
Peterson found himself on a badly
neglected court and was inspired to
repaint the free-throw line it was
something I felt didn't need it
something I felt like I could do
he realized instead of bringing people
together cracked crumbling courts and
urban neighborhoods are often seen as
barriers that drive families away so
Peterson launched project backboard and
reshaped 22 courts across the country
into magical murals playing on courts
that look like this may cause you to
think more creatively if that is one of
the hopes is that people come into this
space and they start imagining what if
color is somewhat of a new thing for me
local artist musee c SE was inspired to
design the oakland court you see some
parts over here that are more of a table
element but it also has this archway
he says his abstract images represent
home and a sense of community
it's important I think to have this
space they can take pride in feel
comfortable and safe there those rainbow
- you mean diversity yeah definitely an
Oakland resident
Cisse knows these children worried about
the violence on their streets so having
this beautiful place to play makes a
powerful statement it's so impactful
when you show
these kids that they matter what did you
think when you walked out here and you
saw the color it's amazing the way it
came out I was just like watching them
from the swings like that's all I did
for like two days straight I wanted to
join in and help to make it all possible
project backboard teams with sponsors
like video game maker NBA 2k the cost
around fifty thousand dollars being out
there and physically playing the game is
so important to kind of develop those
skills that you need in life you need to
know how to cooperate with the team be a
leader that's why we build these courts
and why it's so important to us and the
importance of play and teamwork seems to
be a slam dunk
at the rainbow recreation center I used
to be mean before I came here I didn't
really want to be a role model but now
like I'm nice to everyone everyone knows
my name they'll call me when they need
help or something Oh a colorful change
giving a win to the community for CBS
this morning
Jamie yuccas Oakland California that is
so cool I wouldn't I want a mirror above
the court so I could see what it looks
like all time I'm playing right that's
so nice I think of Danielle Moss
yesterday when she talked about people
believing in you and having those
expectations and just seeing that court
it's so vibrant it's a safe space and
it's beautiful our executive producer
Diana Miller said she wants a print for
all I'm thinking that the sports mind
and going oh you could create a new
three-point line from each color it's a
different amount about great stuff there
Jamie